pour les habitants de marc simeoni la
vie était devenue un peu trop visible
pendant le mois d'août
la petite commune déjà quasiment privés
de réseau mobile c'est en plus de cela
retrouver son téléphone fixe si
quelqu'un tombe où est malade on peut
pas appeler de secours puisqu'on n'a
plus de téléphone
on n'a rien rien rien pas de téléphone
pas de mobile il n'y a plus rien à faire
on attend la tente a duré plusieurs
semaines
de quoi rapidement inquiété la famille
des personnes les plus fragiles un mes
frères qui habitent dans la essayer de
les contacter et n'y arrivant pas il m'a
appelé et c'est là que je suis venu et
que mes parents m'ont dit qu'il n'irait
qu'ils étaient en panne de téléphone
plus de téléphone fixe alors que c'est
encore le seul moyen de communication de
ses parents ils ont plus de 90 ans
ils m'appellent régulièrement pour que
je leur fasse des courses au que j'aille
chercher leurs médicaments
donc effectivement pour eux c'est un
gros problème partant parce qu'on a
toujours besoin de quelque chose on ne
peut pas se déplacer tout au tout les en
avait pas et puis on a du mal à marcher
pour un léger chez quelqu'un à son bras
l'homme de 93 ans porte un bracelet qui
lui permet d'alerter sa famille en cas
de chute
sauf que pour fonctionner ce bracelet a
besoin d'une ligne fixe
c'est essentiel et non ils n'ont que ça
quel téléphone et sa télé assistance ne
fonctionne que s'il ya du téléphone si
ya pas de téléphone ya pas de
téléassistance
contacté par nos soins la mairie assure
faire le nécessaire pour que les
personnes victimes de ces pannes soit
indemnisé et pour qu'à l'avenir les
habitants ne perdent plus leur ligne